I'm often given tasks on the fly,
whereas many of my tasks are given as
a result of meetings these days and
increasing number are coming from emails
or my manager or client asking me to do
something. I find myself quite
disorganized when dealing with this.
I'm writing things down when I'm told,
but it's all over the place.
Postits notebook, phone, et cetera.
I don't have a solid method of
keeping track of these things.
I'm guessing that a possible solution
is to write all these things down in the
same place, but I've also tried that
and didn't really make a difference.
I'd appreciate any input or advice
you have on how to record and track
objectives in a functional,
in a reliable manner.
As I'm subjected to a lot of
information each day, week, month,
I'm definitely overloaded to remember
it myself. Discipline equals freedom,
so yeah, a few things.
First, first of all,
definitely write the things down in one
place and it sounds like since you're
moving all the time or you're going
to meetings carry just a nice little
notebook with you and write the
things down as you get Tash to them.
Then on top of that you have to
have a master list of some kind,
either paper or digital.
I'm going to probably recommend digital
to track things overall in a prioritized
method, so if you get tasked something
in a meeting and your little notebook,
you come back, you put it in the
right place in the master task list
and then
like twice a day to consolidate the
information that's in the little notebook
you have into the big master list and
then before you go to bed at night you
organize those things by
priority on the master list.
You put the most important thing at
the top and that's what you're going to
attack the next day.
That's part one on how you
get these things organized.
Now the part two is you got to schedule
this stuff and actually I always say
this, when people have trouble with
tasks, put them on the calendar.
You don't actually Jamie does that for me.
When Jamie's got something for me to do,
she just doesn't email me and say, hey,
you need to do this. She puts it on the
calendar so I look at my calendar, boom,
there it is. I got to go do
this. Whatever this task is done.
So put these things on your calendar and
that includes scheduling time on your
calendar so that you can have time to
consolidate your list and do a review of
your lists.
You know whether that takes that probably
take 15 minutes to do and I guess
there's a bunch of apps you can
use and I'm sure people will make
recommendations,
but there's a ton of to do list
apps including there's one,
there's native ones on
all the different phones,
so you could look at that as
a possible of voice recorder.
You can either use the voice recorder
app you have or you can carry around a
little mini voice recorder.
Then you can just take notes with that
and then you consolidate those notes from
your,
from Your Voice Recorder into
your master task list every day,
and then you just got to
prioritize and execute
to pretty straight forward.